[Music]
mitchell is with us in salt lake city hi
mitchell how are you
how's it going guys thanks so much for
having me on sure what's up
so
um my whole life i've been
um pretty financially stable i would
consider myself a frugal person
um recently my world got turned upside
down um my wife and i we just had
triplets oh
yeah yeah that's usually the reaction i
get from people
um and it's just really just thrown a
wrench in what and how i've been
planning financially so
um a few months ago well november of
last year we got pregnant and right
around that time we had bought in
our first house it was actually a duplex
and the numbers were so good on the
duplex that we could actually live in
one side completely free the other side
was actually paying for the whole
mortgage and some so we were planning on
living in the duplex
for years a long time
not having any um not having to make any
payments we have debt obviously but we
were comfortable with the debt in that
house
and then when we found out we were
having
triplets
there's just no way we can fit in there
it's it's really it's really small
it's old and we just don't want to raise
our family in there so now
currently
we are
under contract to to buy our first house
and i'm just freaking out because i'm
not i hate that and i just feel like i'm
making a bad financial decision but i
just wanted to reach out to you guys and
see you know what your thoughts are on
on what i'm doing did you sell the
duplex
so we haven't sold the duplex um because
now now we have renters on both sides
i'm not currently living with my parents
and they're helping us with the with the
triplets sell the duplex and
sell the duplex yes
and even so and the cash flow on the
duplexes so right now cash flows if they
pay
you're right they don't always pay
you have stress because you're carrying
a bunch of debt that you can on a rental
property that you can't afford
and if it does if it doesn't work it's
going to go sideways and you're you're
feeling that in your chest
along with the weight of two three
triplets standing on your chest
yes so so you're right there that stress
does i mean yeah i'm just stressed all
the time
no matter what the scenario is i'm just
stressed out well it's because you're
trying to keep everything you're trying
to keep the past dream and and stitch it
to the future new reality and they don't
fit together
dump the duplex move on with your brand
new awesome life but it's a completely
different life than your little plan
ever you you haven't got it through your
head yet everything is different now oh
no
yeah
yes he does
i know that everything's different so
how much is the house payment on the new
house going to be
so
the on the new house the payment would
be about thirty one thirty one hundred
thirty one hundred dollars
nice thirty one hundred
thirty one hundred dollars on the new
house and what is the household income
take-home pay
so household income so my wife currently
she's not working she's she's full-time
mom she had triplets yeah yeah she's for
sure working dude
oh i know she works a lot harder than i
do and i i let her know that she's not
working outside the home okay yeah so
what do you make dude
so i'm doing about two to three hundred
thousand a year you're fine sell the
duplex
here's what's going on okay
you are because i'm you that's how i can
just it's easy for me to read this
because i'm i'm like a super planner
i mean i i know what i'm going to be
doing in march right now
okay it's ridiculous how how
ridiculously
anal i am about this i mean i just i i
love having a plan
i i when we go on vacation i know what
we're going to be doing the whole time
on vacation or it is not relaxing to me
yes
it's not relaxing to me to not know not
knowing is stressful for me okay you're
that guy you're like that right
i i'm the same person you had this all
dialed in
and the car hit the wall i mean it was
like nascar engine up in the stands
doors flew off your plan just
disintegrated
thank goodness it was for a joyful
reason
yeah no they're a blessing but it
completely you're it just you know so
now what you've got to do is you got to
regroup and it's going to take you a
little while to sweep the corners out of
all the wreckage
and now build a new plan with the new
situation and you make a ton of money
you're in a great situation you got
three wonderful babies you've got a
wonderful wife wanting to take care of
them and now you got a nice house to
stay in instead of that cheap butt
duplex you had stuck your wife in making
300 grand
yeah
i haven't even mentioned yet that we
also need to buy a van because they
don't fit in our cars so save up and buy
a little cheap van or pay whatever you
save up whatever you can pay cash for
and then move up a little bit in van
later and get a little better one later
that's the other thing is people these
these these triplets
are teeny tiny little humans
and we feel like oh i'm bringing home a
12
um
pound human or a 10 pound human or a six
pound human they need their own bedroom
their own furniture set their own
they don't they don't take up a mushroom
they don't yet right they will but they
don't you've got a few years they need
three car seats
that's a sedan that's right you know be
uncomfortable and annoying and all that
but you can do it right yep yep yep yep
you're gonna be fine mitchell you're
just going through congratulations
you're in shock yeah you're just going
through shock i mean you're you're a
planner and your plan got destroyed yeah
and until you get your plan rebuilt
you're going to feel the stress and it's
going to take you a little while to get
accustomed to the
new rhythm of life and put the plan in
place and then you're gonna be there but
i mean it's what you say all the time
you gotta grieve the thing that you what
you thought it's gonna be it's not gonna
be so you gotta you gotta you have to
grieve that and go i thought this kind
of yes i'm i can't say out loud babies
suck but three of them at one time
it's hard it kind of sucks a little bit
you know and then there's then there's
awesome all the awesomeness but there's
a little bit of you that goes ah that's
right you know and so that's reality and
that's okay but you're not allowed to
say that out loud i know i'll get
trashed on twitter just because i said
that so yeah it's gonna get fresh on
twitter every day that's exactly right
hey so let me ask you a mechanic's
question um let's say he was gonna
profit a hundred grand from the sale of
this duplex yep it'd appreciate that
much
would it be best for him to take let's
i'm assuming his house payment's
probably about 500 000 it's gonna be his
mortgage so would it be better for him
to
put a hundred thousand dollars down and
drop that 3100 a month to 2800 a month
or to just go ahead and make the loan
and then immediately dump 100 grand on
top of it because i think he's already
got the house
okay no no no it's under contract under
contract yeah if you get the duplex hold
in time put it as additional down
payment and have a smaller payment
because that would be like because
that's a i would throw it all unless you
need a little over to buy a van but
there you go the rest of it i mean let's
be dead he said he was debt-free so what
what kind of van are we going to buy
making 300 grand i mean go get you i
like the idea of collapsing that uh
monthly payment as much as i can yeah
yeah well i always put everything down
on the house i can above the emergency
fund and above in this case a new van
and the second and third baby bed and so
whatever it is you got to buy right and
so it's it's just it's a thing but
mitchell you're going through
a normal human adjustment to a shock to
your system
and that causes stress right
and if you didn't feel
all of this in the form of stress you
would be psychotic you go see a doctor
right yeah and so you know normal humans
when they go through what you have gone
through have a ah
moment you know that you know just so
the good news is you're normal right and
let's chip chip away at it right because
if you're a planner you've already
started thinking oh gosh i'm gonna have
to hunt have a hundred thousand dollars
a semester for these three and so don't
go 20 years down the road and start
creating catastrophes that you've got to
solve today
just start following the plan chip away
didn't chip away at it
old minister was working the altar and a
friend of mine young boy came forward
and years ago and told me this story he
became a pastor later and he said this
guy was a visiting evangelist and he
went up and he asked for prayer he said
i'm having i'm 14 years old he said i'm
having lustful thoughts about girls and
the minister laid his hands on him and
he prayed lord thank you this boy is
normal
just
relieve you of the stress yeah i mean
you're normal mitchell i mean this is
what you're in you're in this situation
and so you're normal thank goodness
you're okay now you're gonna work
through the things that are causing you
anxiety limit them develop a plan cut
loose the old stuff from the old dream
the duplex is gone and we move forward
into the new jersey
landlord and then everything will calm
back down and you'll get your little
planting self together i know this
because i have to do it all the time
this is how i live my life so i'm right
there with you brother